la france doit-elle débaptiser des rues
et des monuments aux noms de
personnalités esclavagiste c'est ce que
réclament plusieurs associations et
collectifs à paris la statue de jean
baptiste colbert devant l'assemblée
nationale a été prise pour cible lors de
la manifestation mémoire adama traoré
c'était le 13 juin pour en parler en
direct avec nous louis georges tin
président d'honneur du cran
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt font alors emmanuel
macouin été formel lors de son
allocution de dimanche à la république
n'effacera aucun nom aucune trace de son
histoire il semble fermée aux débats oui
alors que le monde entier dit bas de ces
questions il faut rappeler à monsieur
macron qu' il n'a pas autorité sur ces
matières par exemple les noms de rues
dépendent du maire les noms des lycées
colbert dépendent des proviseurs par
conséquent ce n'est pas lui qui décide
tout en france quand il dit la france ne
dise vous donnera pas je veux dire bien
monsieur mâcon vous n'êtes pas la france
la france c'est nous tous alors
justement on à jean marc ayrault ans et
président de la fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavagé qui a demandé lui
justement à rebaptiser une salle colbert
à l'assemblée nationale on voit des
manifestement la vie d'emmanuel
m'apprenez pas forcément partagé par
tous les membres du gouvernement
en tout cas de la grèce antique
française exactement
rappelons quand même qu'ils colbert
c'est l'auteur d'un double crime contre
l'humanité c'est lui qui a par exemple
cordonnier le code noir qui organise la
verge en france c'est lui aussi qui a
créé la compagnie des indes de sinistre
mémoire
or l'assemblée nationale la maison du
peuple
liberté égalité fraternité mais colbert
c'était l'ennemi de la liberté d'ennemis
d'égalité l'ennemi la fraternité donc
c'est une contradiction c'est une
abomination
alors on demande à retirer à des
symboles des représentations du
colonialisme français
est ce que c'est un peu une demande
venant quand on sait qu'il ya des
personnalités politiques donc parfois
même des décisionnaires qui défont le
côté positif de ce colonialisme
oui mais l'assemblée nationale à
l'unanimité a voté la loi taubira qui
dit que l'esclavagé est un crime contre
l'humanité donc on dit des scrutins
j'attaquerai contre l'humanité de la
limiter et en même temps on soutient la
statue de l'esclavagé listel moi je ne
comprends plus ce message et je le dis
très clairement
moi je suis martiniquais par exemple
comment voulez vous que nous fassions
france lorsque vos héros sont nos
bourreaux
alors certains ont parlé d' intégrer des
panneaux explicatifs justement ça a été
le cas par exemple à bordeaux
qu'est ce que vous en pensez une eau
honorer une rumeur parce que contenant
le nom de noa quelqu'un c'est qu'on
l'honore et expliqué que c'est un
fervent défenseur de l'esclavagisme par
exemple ou du colonialisme quel est
l'intérêt d'axa n'a pas beaucoup de sens
est ce qu'on va faire une rue pétain en
disant pétain que la boue notoire
certains beaucoup de sens
donc je crois qu'il faut pas que faire
de contorsions avec les valeurs
républicaines il faut pas finalement
faire les choses à moitié il faut pas
détruire ses statuts mais il faut les
mettre au bon endroit
l'assemblée nationale ce n'est pas le
bon endroit il faut les mettre dans un
musée de l'esclavagé que nous avons
d'ailleurs demandé et obtenu de la
mairie de paris
donc les rues doivent être rebaptisé il
faut organiser des commissions locales
dans les villes avec les riverains les
historiens les élus les associations et
ça concerne esclavage cela concerne
aussi la collaboration
donc il faut simplement un dialogue
national je vois que monsieur macron
aime beaucoup la méthode participative
des grands débats mais quand on parle de
l'histoire de france il n'y a plus de
débat possible avec lui c'est pas grave
on discutera avec les personnes
compétentes
ce n'est pas lui qui décide ce seront
les élus locaux les riverains etc
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons avancer
alors la france était dans un déni de
son passé colonial c'est en tout cas ce
que votre association plein d'autres
collectifs pense estime aujourd'hui
absolument oui parce que si cette
histoire qui est extrêmement cacher
quand il dit la république ne vais pas
cacher mais c'est faux pendant des
décennies on a voulu cacher cette
histoire la loi taubira a été acceptée
avec de très très longues difficulté la
date nationale c'était très difficile
donc quand il dit il faut pas cacher
j'ai envie de dire mais c'est vous
justement les institutions françaises
qui avaient voulu cacher cette histoire
aujourd'hui nous faisons tout un travail
qui permet de mettre sur la table ces
réalités longtemps occultée donc c'est
nous qui vous mettons l'histoire sur la
table c'est le gouvernement souvent qui
essaie de la cacher louis georges tin
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et d'avoir été en direct sur rt france
rappelle que vous êtes président
d'honneur du croit merci